a sprawling camp for the displaced in my
degree it's one of dozens dotting the
landscape of northeastern Nigeria in
some of the camp's aid workers hand out
soap and water in the race to improve
personal hygiene as more coronavirus
infractions and deaths are reported
people are complained very well the
level of compliance as you can see is
here the Securities are the gates quite
around trying to enforce in fact I even
cited somebody who wanted to gain access
to the camp and then they fastened
actually declined to wash his hand and
of course he was denied access but the
residents here are undernourished with
some having to wait in lines to fetch
drinking water our crowding is another
major problem making social distancing
almost impossible there's no support or
any donation that was encouraged hygiene
and healthy lifestyles but yet they are
still making emphasis on coughing
etiquettes good personal hygiene so how
do you expect the less privileged in the
camp to cope with this situation we are
always praying that's all we can do this
is a test from Almighty God so we ought
to accept it with good faith 10 years of
war with Boko Haram the group fighting
against Nigeria's army has forced more
than two and a half million people from
their homes into camps like this the
United Nations announced emergency
response measures to mitigate the spread
of coronavirus among the most vulnerable
in the Northeast but organizations such
as Doctors Without Borders say the
situation in the camps is dire
it's made worse by the continuing Boko
Haram attacks not only in northeastern
Nigeria but in neighboring Cameroon Chad
initial Republic many fear a corona
virus outbreak in these camps could be
catastrophic I fear that's becoming more
real with health facilities crumbling
across the country how many trees
al-jazeera